I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey.
We were on The Office together and we're best friends.
And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you.
Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews
behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories.
We're the Office Lady 6.0.
Hello.
Hi.
我是珍娜·费舍，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们为你带来了终极的《办公室》爱好者播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节和大量闺蜜故事，深入探讨《办公室》的世界。我们是办公室辣妹6.0版。你好。嗨。
So, lady, you know that the day that this podcast airs,
we are going to be walking the Nimrod's Red Carpet.
Oh my gosh.
It's the day of the premiere.
Today?
Today.
When everyone hears this, that's what we'll be doing.
That evening.
所以，亲爱的，你知道这个播客播出的那天，我们要去走“小顽童”的红毯。哦，天哪。今天是首映日。今天？今天。当大家听到这个的时候，这就是我们要去做的事情。那天晚上。
Oh, my gosh.
Followed by a big old party.
It's going to be fun.
I haven't done one of those in a long time.
Me either.
And I'm actually kind of excited.
Oh, my gosh.
I never remember how to stand or where to put my hand.
哦，天哪。后面还有一个盛大的派对。这会很有趣的。我好久没去过那种场合了。我也是。其实我还有点兴奋。哦，天哪。我从来不记得该怎么站或者手该往哪里放。
I have to practice.
Let's practice.
Okay.
We'll do what we do because you have to do this.
You have to put on your outfit.
Yeah.
And you have to have someone take.
pictures of you in different poses. And then what I do is I pick the one very good one. And that's the only
我得练习一下。我们练习一下。好吧。我们会像平时那样做，因为你必须这么做。你得穿上你的行头。对。还得找人拍下你各种姿势的照片。然后我要做的是，挑出一张非常好的。而我只会
way I'll stand. It doesn't matter if they yell at me. It doesn't matter if they say over the shoulder.
I only know this one way to stand. That's it. I literally, the minute I get on a red carpet,
completely forget all the things I practice and then I stand like an idiot. I know. Same.
Okay. Well, maybe there's a learning curve. Who knows. But before we're at the Nimrod's premiere on the
Red Carpet, we have a really special episode for you guys to listen to today.
In the studio with us is hilarious comedian and actor Bobby Lee.
So fun.
Yes.
以这种方式站着。不管他们对我大喊大叫。不管他们说看镜头。我只知道这一个站姿。就是这样。我真的，一踏上红毯，就把我练习的所有东西忘得精光，然后像个白痴一样站着。我知道。我也是。好吧。也许有一个学习曲线。谁知道呢。但在我们去参加“小顽童”红毯首映之前，我们今天为你们准备了一期非常特别的节目。和我们一起在演播室的是搞笑喜剧演员兼演员鲍比·李。太有趣了。是的。
And Jenna, you did a television show with Bobby.
I did.
Yes, we did two seasons of the ABC show splitting up together.
And we talk a little bit about that today.
We do.
We hash a few things out from that time.
You did.
But you guys, today, as we're getting ready to walk that premiere red carpet for Nimbabye,
珍娜，你和鲍比一起拍过一部电视剧。是的，我们拍过两季ABC的电视剧《离婚合伙人》。我们今天会稍微聊聊那个。对。我们把那段时间的一些事情拿出来聊聊。你确实聊了。但是各位，今天，当我们准备为“Nimbabye”的红毯首映做准备时，
for Nimrods, we are going to be talking all about it because you guys get to see it out in theaters
this Friday, August 14th. Yeah, you guys, I am so, so excited about this movie. Okay, here's what
it's about. This movie stars Mason Tames as Tommy, and he gets a phone call inviting his teen punk band
to open for Green Day on New Year's Eve. Amazing. Amazing. Unfortunately, he does not realize
that this is actually an elaborate prank. So, believing that his life is about to change,
He sets out on a road trip with his bandmates who are played by Kyler Kaufman and Ryan Faust.
And y'all, this movie is produced with Green Day.
And Green Day was part of writing the story.
为“小顽童”，我们要好好聊聊这部电影，因为你们本周五（8月14日）就可以在电影院看到它了。是的，伙计们，我对这部电影感到非常非常兴奋。好吧，剧情是这样的。这部电影由马森·泰姆斯饰演汤米，他接到一个电话，邀请他的青少年朋克乐队在除夕夜为绿日乐队暖场。太棒了。太棒了。不幸的是，他没有意识到这其实是一个精心策划的恶作剧。所以，他以为自己的人生就要改变了，于是和他的乐队成员（由凯勒·考夫曼和瑞安·福斯特饰演）踏上了公路旅行。各位，这部电影是由绿日乐队参与制作的。而且绿日乐队还参与了故事的编写。
Yeah, it's sort of based loosely on their early days as a band.
Yes, the stuff that happens to these kids in the movie on their way to Los Angeles
to quote unquote open for Green Day was inspired by Green Day's early days of touring in a van
together before their breakout record, Duky.
So like pre-Dukee, these are the things that happened to Green Day.
The movie was written and also directed by my husband Lee Kirk.
And Jenna, Lee spent hours with Billy Joe, the band, right?
Developing the stories and everything.
是的，这大致取材于他们早年作为乐队的日子。是的，电影里这些孩子在去洛杉矶“为绿日暖场”的路上发生的种种，灵感就来自于绿日乐队在成名专辑《Dookie》问世前，开着面包车一起巡演的早期经历。所以在《Dookie》之前，绿日乐队就是经历过这些事情的。这部电影由我的丈夫李·科克编剧并执导。珍娜，李和比利·乔（乐队成员）花了好几个小时，对吧？一起开发故事和所有内容。
Yes, it started because Billy Joe called Lee and said,
I would really like to do a Green Day movie.
They had collaborated before.
So, yes, Lee interviewed the band, and then he weaved their stories into the script.
So I was talking to Trey Kuhl, the drummer of Great Day.
I was just talking to him.
It's not a big deal.
I know, I know.
是的，这是因为比利·乔给李打电话说，我真的很想拍一部绿日乐队的电影。他们之前合作过。所以，是的，李采访了乐队，然后把他们的故事编织进了剧本里。所以我跟绿日乐队的鼓手特雷·库尔聊过。我刚刚还跟他聊过呢。这没什么大不了的。我懂，我懂。
I talked to Mike.
I know.
I know, lady.
I know how much you're geeking out.
But I was talking to Trey.
And he called the movie Historical Fiction, which I thought was a really good description.
Because it's not a biopic, but there's a lot of things in the movie that are from their lives.
Like, for example, in the movie, the character of Fred, played by Kyler Kaufman, has this puppet.
我跟迈克聊过。我懂。我懂，亲爱的。我知道你有多狂热。但我是在和特雷聊天。他把这部电影称为“历史小说”，我觉得这个形容真的很贴切。因为它不是传记片，但电影里有很多事情都取材于他们的生活。比如，在电影中，由凯勒·考夫曼饰演的弗雷德这个角色，有一个木偶
that he takes on the road named Gravy.
And Gravy does all these bad puns,
and he, like, drives the other guy's nuts.
And in the early days, Mike had a puppet named Gravy.
Oh.
Mm-hmm.
And also, if you are a super big Green Day fan,
you're going to see an appearance by Sleepy.
他带着这个名叫“格雷维”的木偶上路。格雷维总是说一些烂笑话，让人抓狂。而在早期，迈克确实有一个名叫格雷维的木偶。哦。嗯。而且，如果你是绿日乐队的超级铁粉，你会看到“沉睡者”客串。
And that's all I'm going to say.
Green Day fans, he will know who Sleepy is.
And then, of course, the movie is also just full of fantastic Green Day songs.
Yes.
And Lee got to choose songs from the entire.
Green Day catalog. They said whatever song you want. The soundtrack for this movie is sick. That's what
the kids say. Are you being hit? I learned that on the movie. They call it sick. Okay. But everyone,
it is really such a fun movie. It's multi-generational. The young cast is incredible. I mentioned
我只能说这么多了。绿日粉丝们，你们会知道“沉睡者”是谁的。当然，电影里也充满了绿日乐队的经典好歌。是的。而且李从绿日乐队的整个曲库中挑选了歌曲。他们说你想用哪首歌都行。这部电影的原声带太酷了。年轻人们都这么说。你被打了吗？我是从电影里学到的。他们管这叫“酷”。好吧。不过各位，这真的是一部非常有趣的电影。它适合全年龄段观看。年轻演员阵容太棒了。我提到了
Mason, Kyler, and Ryan. But it also stars McKenna Grace, Ignacio Diaz, Silverio, and Keene Ruffalo.
And then you've also got Fred Armisen, Sean Gunn, me, Angela, and our guest today,
Bobby Lee, who plays Otis the Security Guard.
What a lineup.
Yeah.
I mean, what a group.
And listen, you guys, Bobby is so funny in the movie.
And I really loved our interview with him.
马森、凯勒和瑞安。但主演还有麦肯纳·格雷斯、伊格纳西奥·迪亚斯·西尔维里奥和基恩·鲁法洛。此外，还有弗莱德·阿米森、肖恩·冈恩、我（安吉拉），以及我们今天的嘉宾鲍比·李，他饰演保安奥蒂斯。这阵容太豪华了。是的。我是说，这群人太棒了。听着，各位，鲍比在电影里的表现太搞笑了。我真的很喜欢我们对他的采访。
I think you guys are going to enjoy it.
It has some twists and turns.
I was not expecting.
Same.
I mean, we do some real sharing.
We do.
And some real laughing.
Well, listen, before we get to our amazing interview with Bobby Lee, we do have a fan chit-check question.
我想你们也会喜欢的。里面有一些我没预料到的转折。我也是。我是说，我们分享了一些很真实的事情。确实。还有很多真诚的笑声。好了，听着，在我们开始对鲍比·李进行精彩的采访之前，我们先来回答一个粉丝的闲聊问题。
This is from Brianna R in St. Michael's Maryland.
who said,
Hello, office ladies.
My husband and I are considering quitting our day jobs and opening our own business.
I'm a little nervous about mixing my home life with my work life.
Sometimes it's nice to have a separate space away from your significant other.
And while I love my husband to pieces,
I worry a little bit about us working together and being together all the time.
这是来自马里兰州圣迈克尔斯的布里安娜·R提问的，她说：“你好，办公室辣妹。我和我丈夫正在考虑辞去日间工作，自己创业。我对把家庭生活和工作生活混在一起有点紧张。有时候，拥有一个远离另一半的独立空间挺好的。虽然我深爱着我的丈夫，但我还是有点担心我们一起工作、整天黏在一起会怎么样。”
And then also being mom and dad.
Since you have both worked with your husbands professionally,
I wondered if you would be willing to share a little about
how that worked for you. P.S., and I loved this, I couldn't figure out how to upload an audio file,
but I hope you will still pick this question. I hope you won't find it too personal to share.
Love the podcast. Oh, Brianna, I wouldn't know how to do the audio file either, so no worries there.
This was such a thoughtful question. Yeah. I mean, first of all, it's a big thing to just pivot in life
and start your own business. Clearly, you have to be a very important.
“然后还要扮演爸爸妈妈的角色。既然你们俩都和自己的丈夫有过专业合作，我想知道你们是否愿意分享一下这其中的运作方式。”顺便说一句，我很喜欢这个，“我不知道怎么上传音频文件，但我希望你们还是会挑中这个问题。希望你们不会觉得这太私人而不好意思分享。超爱这个播客。”哦，布里安娜，我也不知道怎么弄音频文件，所以不用担心。这是一个非常有深度的提问。是的。我是说，首先，在生活中突然转型去创业是一件大事。很显然，你得有一份非常重要的
some day job and you're like, I'm going to do a different thing. But then also to take that on
with your significant other. Yeah. You know, this is going to be what you guys are doing. And I can relate,
Angela, as I'm sure you can. Yeah. I mean, we've both been in business with our husbands.
We have. I mean, it's how I met and fell in love with my husband was doing a film. And since then,
we did Ashland Avenue, the play, and now Nimrods. I love.
working with my husband. We work great together. It's wonderful. He's one of my favorite people to
create with. I admire him and respect him as an artist, and he feels the same. And I think if you have
that mutual respect with your partner, then I think you can be in business together. Yeah, I agree.
日间工作，然后你却说：“我要去做点别的事情。”但接着还要和你的另一半一起承担这一切。是的。你知道，这将是你们两个一起做的事情。我能感同身受，安吉拉，我相信你也是。是的。我是说，我们俩都和自己的丈夫一起做过生意。我们确实做过。我是说，我和我丈夫就是通过拍电影相识并相恋的。从那以后，我们做过话剧《艾什兰大道》，现在又有了《小顽童》。我喜欢
And I also think something that works well for Josh and I, which I also think works well with me and
you, Jenna, is that we both have different things we're good at. And I'm so thankful for that.
because when Josh and I did all of the baking stuff and our YouTube baking show, he's just so great
at baking and cooking and the recipes and curating them. And I'm sort of like color commentary,
you know, and the two of us each bring our own thing. And I so appreciate what he brought
and he was appreciative of what I brought. So it was easy to work together because of that.
Well, I'm glad you brought up us, Angela, because I thought of us going into business together
as best friends when I saw Brianna's question, because I would say that the one thing, and this is true when I'm doing a project Lee, and it's true with our best friendship, is that the one pitfall to being in business with your significant other or best friend is where suddenly you forget to have the other conversations.
和我的丈夫一起工作。我们合作得很好。太棒了。他是我最喜欢一起创作的人之一。我作为艺术家很钦佩他、尊重他，他也是这么看我的。我觉得如果你和伴侣之间有这种相互尊重，那么你们就可以一起做生意。是的，我也这么觉得。
Yes, that is so true.
Because you're only talking about work.
Yeah, and you want to make sure you're still a couple.
and you still have that, all the things that make you a couple, you know, not a business partner.
Right.
And so when we were really in the middle of our cookbook and all of our conversations were about the cookbook,
I remember us being like both at the same time, like, we need to go away for the weekend.
We need to just go stay at a little bed and breakfast and go for a hike and go on a date night
而且我也觉得，对乔和我来说很管用的一点——我也觉得对我和你，珍娜，同样管用——那就是我们俩擅长不同的领域。我对此非常感激。因为当乔和我做所有的烘焙相关的事情以及我们的YouTube烘焙秀时，他非常擅长烘焙、烹饪、研究食谱并把它们整理出来。而我有点像是负责插科打诨的解说员，你知道的，我们俩各展所长。我非常感激他带来的东西，他也感激我带来的东西。正因如此，我们合作起来非常轻松。好吧，很高兴你提到了我们，安吉拉，因为当我看到布里安娜的问题时，我想到了我们作为好朋友一起合伙做生意的经历，因为我想说的是，有那么一件事——当我和李合作项目时是这样，在我们最好的友谊中也是这样——与你的另一半或最好朋友一起做生意的唯一陷阱，就是你们突然忘记了进行其他方面的交流。
and just not talk work, you know, because that's what feeds the partnership is,
everything you do outside of the business is what makes you want to do the business together.
Does that make sense?
Yes, because we do that as best friends.
And you're really good at that, Angela.
You'll say, I want to have a conversation and we are not allowed to talk about work.
Mm-hmm.
Like, period.
是的，太对了。因为你们满脑子谈的都是工作。是的，你得确保你们依然是一对情侣。你们依然拥有那些让你们成为情侣的所有特质，你知道的，而不是单纯的商业伙伴。没错。所以当我们的食谱书进入白热化阶段，我们所有的对话都围绕着食谱书时，我记得我们俩同时都在说：我们需要出去过周末。我们需要去一家小小的民宿住几天，去远足，去进行一次约会，
Best friend stories only.
Yeah.
Domestic life stories only.
You said it to me just this morning, because we trade messages every day.
You guys know that, right?
We leave each other voice notes.
And especially when we're both busy running.
errands, you know? And I love nothing more to see that I have a voice note from you, but you said this
就是不聊工作，你知道的，因为正是这一切在滋养着你们的关系，你在生意之外所做的一切，才是让你想和对方一起把生意做下去的动力。这说得通吗？说得通，因为我们作为好朋友也是这么做的。而且你在这方面真的很在行，安吉拉。你会说：“我想聊聊天，而且我们绝对不准谈工作。”嗯哼。就这么定了。
morning, because I had left you one. I was like, you're like, is this boring? This is so stupid.
This is so boring. This is the lamest message. And you were like, Angie, I loved it. It was
slice of life. I love slice of life. Yeah. It's important to keep that in the relationship,
Brianna. So I guess that's our advice is find out what strengths you each have, respect those
separate things, learn how to work with them, and then also still make time for each other as husband
and wife. I think that's great advice. I mean, I don't know what it is your planning to do,
but if you do take that leap, I wish you all the success. Yeah, just all the good things coming
your way. All right. Well, listen, why don't we take a break? And then we are going to be back with
只能聊闺蜜故事。对。只能聊家庭生活琐事。你今天早上还跟我这么说过呢，因为我们每天都互发消息。大家知道的，对吧？我们给彼此留语音留言。尤其是当我们在两头奔忙、办杂事的时候，你知道吗？没有什么比看到我有你的语音留言更让我开心的了，但你今天早上却这么说，因为我给你留了一条。我当时就想，你就像是在说：“这会不会很无聊？这太蠢了。这太无聊了。这是最无趣的信息了。”而你却说：“安吉拉，我太喜欢了。这就是生活本来的切片。我爱生活切片。”是的。把这种感觉保持在关系中是很重要的，布里安娜。所以我想我们的建议是：找出你们各自的优势，尊重这些不同的特质，学会如何与它们相处，同时还要抽出时间像夫妻一样陪伴彼此。我觉得这是很好的建议。我是说，我不知道你们打算做什么，但如果你们真的迈出那一步，我祝你们一切顺利。是的，祝你们一切顺利。好吧，听着，我们为什么不休息一下？然后我们将带着
Bobby Lee. Every week on the Moth podcast, you'll hear true stories that will intrigue you,
inspire you and make you laugh.
When I was 14 years old, I had a deeply meaningful experience, something so real that I knew
it was going to shape who I was to become for the rest of my life.
I saw The Spice Girls on MTV.
For Real Stories, Live on Stage, from astronauts, accountants, comedians, farmers, and people
just like you, follow and listen to The Moth wherever you get your podcasts.
We already started, right?
鲍比·李回归。每周在《蛾》播客节目中，你都会听到真实的故事，它们会吸引你、激励你并让你开怀大笑。在我14岁那年，我经历了一段意义非凡的经历，那是如此真实，以至于我知道它将塑造我余下的人生。我在MTV上看到了辣妹组合。收听来自宇航员、会计师、喜剧演员、农民以及像你一样普通人的真实故事，感受现场直播，无论你在哪里收听播客，都可以关注并收听《蛾》。我们已经开始了，对吧？
You're recording?
Yeah, we're in.
Can I do my own self- intro?
Or do you want to do it?
Yeah.
I'm a comedian, sometimes actor, and I'm Bobby Lee.
Hi, Bobby.
你在录音吗？对，开始了。我能自己做自我介绍吗？还是你想来？可以。是的。我是个喜剧演员，偶尔客串演员，我是鲍比·李。嗨，鲍比。
Yeah, yeah.
And how we know each other is we did a sitcom together.
Splitting up together.
And I want to apologize.
I don't know if I ever apologized to you for not showing up that morning.
Which morning did you not show up?
Remember that one morning that I slept in?
对，对。我们认识是因为我们一起拍了一部情景喜剧。《离婚合伙人》。《离婚合伙人》。我想道个歉。我不知道我有没有为那天早上没去现场向你道过歉。你哪天早上没去？还记得有一次我睡过头了吗？
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God.
I do now.
Yeah.
So I woke up.
Angela.
Yeah.
Wait, can I ask what your call time was?
哦，对。哦，天哪。现在想起来了。对。所以那天我醒了。安吉拉。对。等等，我可以问问你的通告时间是几点吗？
Like six in the morning.
Okay.
So you had an early call time.
So it's now 10.30.
Uh-oh.
Okay?
And I'm in my house.
Yeah.
大概早上六点。好吧。所以你的通告时间很早。现在是10点30分。哦哦。好吧？而我在家里。对。
Sleeping.
I remember.
Did someone come knock on your door?
They entered my room, my house.
So he came into your house.
Yes.
That's what I thought.
Yeah.
在睡觉。我记得。有人去敲你的门吗？他们直接进了我的房间，我的家。所以他进你家里了？对。我是这么想的。对。
And then I felt somebody like roaming around the living room.
Oh, that's creepy.
It's creepy, yeah.
And I come out and I realize, as,
soon as I see the person, what time is it and the panic of it?
Oh, no.
Who did they send?
Like a PA or something?
然后我感觉到有人在客厅里走来走去。哦，那太诡异了。确实诡异，对。然后我走出来，一看到那个人，我就意识到：几点了？然后恐慌感就来了。哦，不。他们派了谁来？制片助理什么的吗？
Yeah, yeah, like a PA or something.
Yeah.
I remember the conversation on set.
It was like, they shot your coverage first.
Was it a scene with me?
Yeah, it was you.
You were waiting.
对，对，制片助理什么的。对。我记得我们在片场聊过。对。当时是先拍你的正反打镜头。是和我的一场戏吗？对，就是你。你在等。
You were doing all your coverage.
I was.
Yeah.
And I came in with my pajamas.
Oh.
I was freaking out.
That kind of panic is just right to your core.
你在拍你的所有镜头。我在拍。对。然后我穿着睡衣进来了。哦。我当时快吓死了。我当时吓坏了。那种恐慌感直接刺痛你的核心。
Has that ever happened to you?
I mean, I've woken up late.
Actually, the time it happened to me, stakes were a little bit lower because it was when
I was an operator at 1-800 dentist.
And I had the 6 a.m. shift, and I overslept.
Yeah.
How old were you?
In my 20s, like around, probably 26.
你经历过这种事吗？我是说，我有过睡醒晚了的时候。实际上，我经历那次的时候，情况没那么严重，因为那是我在1-800-DENTIST（牙医预约热线）当接线员的时候。我上的是早上6点的班，结果我睡过头了。对。你当时多大？二十多岁，大概26岁左右吧。
And the guy called me who was managing the call center.
And I woke up out of this dead sleep.
And my home phone rang, and I was like, hello?
And he was like, Angela, you are two.
hours late for your shift. And I was like, yeah, I'm going to go back to sleep.
You went to sleep. You got fired. No, you would think I did not get fired. I was like, okay,
I'm coming. What's an operator? An operator at 1-800 dentist? Yeah, so I call.
Okay, ring, ring. 1-800 dentist, this is Angela. Do you need a checkup and cleaning today,
管理呼叫中心的那个家伙给我打电话。我从死一般的睡眠中醒过来。我的座机响了，我说：“喂？”他说：“安吉拉，你上班迟到两小时了。”我说：“好吧，我要回去睡觉了。”你又去睡觉了。你被解雇了吧。不，你肯定以为我被解雇了。我说：“好的，我这就去。”接线员是干什么的？1-800-DENTIST的接线员？对，所以我就接电话。好吧，铃，铃。1-800-DENTIST，我是安吉拉。您今天需要做检查和洗牙，
or do you have a specific dental problem? Yeah, all my teeth hurt. Okay, well, you know what? We're going
to get you in to see someone that can help you with that. Oh, so that's what you do. Do you have a PPO or an
We're going.
We're going to keep going.
Cash.
I'm going to pay cash.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I'm going to pay cash.
还是有特定的牙齿问题？对，我牙齿全疼。好吧，你知道吗？我们要给你安排一个能帮你解决这个问题的人。哦，原来你们是这么干的。你有PPO医保还是现金。我们要继续了。现金。我要付现金。哦，好吧。对，我要付现金。
Okay.
Well, there's several dentists who will take you of your paying cash.
Yeah.
So I overslept.
And then he told me you overslept.
And then I was like, yes, I did.
Yeah.
好吧。如果你付现金的话，有几位牙医愿意接诊。对。对。所以我睡过头了。然后他告诉我你睡过头了。然后我说：“是的，我确实睡过头了。”对。
And then I did get up and go in.
But I was like, I'm just a sleep, just a little bit more.
Yeah, you need that extra.
Yeah, go ahead.
What happened when you got to set?
What I remember is us going from being like,
like kind of like annoyed, like, oh, he's late.
But you were not late.
然后我确实起床赶过去了。但我当时的想法是：再睡一会儿，就一会儿。对，你需要额外补充睡眠。对，继续。你到片场的时候发生什么了？我记得我们的反应是从一开始的有点恼火，觉得“哦，他迟到了”。但你平时不是会迟到的人。
You weren't a late person.
You generally were very punctual and you knew your shit.
Yes.
Right.
So you were very punctual today.
Yeah, I'm punctual.
You were 10 minutes early.
I'm a punctual person.
你不是那种会迟到的人。你通常非常守时，而且业务能力很强。是的。对吧。所以你那天其实很准时。对，我很准时。你早到了10分钟。我是个很准时的人。
This is what I mean.
Yeah.
Like, we're on set.
And it's like by 630, we actually are worried.
Like we've moved from just like.
Yeah.
And we're like he.
I could have died.
这就是我想说的。对。我们在片场。到了6:30左右，我们其实开始担心了。我们已经不仅仅是……对。我们心想，他。我可能已经死了。
We were concerned.
Yeah. And so there was like this great release when the PA was like, he's okay. He's coming. He just overslept. We were like, oh. Yeah. We were like worried for you.
But what was scary is at the end of the night. What happened? The showrunner came up to me.
Oh, did you get like a talking to? And she just, she walked this way and I was sitting down. Yeah.
And she put her hand on my shoulder. Yeah. And she goes, don't ever do that again.
Oh my gosh. And I was.
scared.
I would have been scared.
我们当时很担心。对。所以当制片助理说“他没事，他正在路上，只是睡过头了”的时候，大家都长舒了一口气。我们心想：“哦。”对。我们当时真的很为你担心。但可怕的是，在当晚收工的时候。发生什么了？制片人向我走来。哦，你被训话了吗？她就这样走过来，当时我正坐着。对。她把手搭在我的肩膀上。对。然后她说：“永远别再这样了。”哦，天哪。我当时。
Were you going to scared?
I would have been scared.
Yeah.
I want to talk about something else from splitting up together.
Okay, go ahead.
I know.
You talked about this time you were late.
Okay.
吓坏了。我要是也会吓坏的。你会吓坏吗？我会吓坏的。对。我想聊聊《离婚合伙人》里的另一件事。好吧，你说吧。我知道。你谈过你迟到的那次。好吧。
Should we talk about?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Should we discuss?
No, because I'll tell you why.
Why?
I think I know what you're getting at.
You've talked about it on your podcast.
Yeah, it's fine.
我们应该聊聊吗？等等，等等，等等。我们要讨论吗？不，因为我告诉你为什么。为什么？我想我知道你要说什么了。你在你的播客里说过这事。好吧，没关系。
So now you're here.
Okay, what you're saying, may I say it or no?
Yes, you already have talked about it, and I just wanted to know.
Yeah, but not in front of you.
Yeah, yeah, I don't want to talk about it with you.
Too late.
She's been tagged in all the real.
Okay, so here's the thing.
所以你现在提出来了。好吧，你要说的，我是可以说还是不能说？是的，你已经说过了，我只是想知道。对，但不是当着你的面。对，对，我不想跟你聊这个。太迟了。她在所有的花絮里都被圈出来了。好吧，事情是这样的。
You know, I don't know if people know about shooting things, but there's coverage.
Is that what you're talking about?
Like on a phone incident.
Yeah, so it's on you, the camera, right?
So I'm doing lines with, yeah, go ahead, Angela.
So let's set it up.
We're on the set of ABC's splitting up together.
I'll set the scene for you.
你知道，我不知道大家懂不懂拍戏是怎么回事，但有正反打。你是说这个吗？比如关于手机的那个插曲。对，就是镜头对着你，对吧？所以我跟你对台词，对，继续，安吉拉。我们来还原一下场景。我们在ABC《离婚合伙人》的片场。我来给你们描述一下这个场景。
It's like the Christmas episode.
If I remember correctly, we're like dressed in like Christmas.
onesies. It's a big group scene. Everyone's in it. Like all the kids are in it, you're in it,
Oliver's in it, Lindsay, Diane. Everybody's in this, right? Am I remembering the right scene?
Yes. And it's in the living room, there's a Christmas tree. Yes. And I have to stand up in front
of the tree and face all of you guys and give this like kind of like emotional. And you did a
great job. Like I had to well up with tears a little bit and then hold them back. It was like
a whole thing, right? Yep. So there's one camera.
就像是圣诞节那一集。如果我没记错的话，我们都穿着圣诞连体衣。这是一场大群戏。所有人都出场了。所有的孩子都在里面，你在里面，奥利弗在里面，林德赛，黛安。所有人都参与了，对吧？我没记错这个场景吧？是的。场景在客厅里，有一棵圣诞树。是的。我得站在树前，面对着你们所有人，发表一段有点像……情绪化的演讲。你做得很好。我当时得眼里含着泪水，然后把它憋回去。这是一个完整的桥段，对吧？没错。所以只有一个镜头。
We do your coverage where the camera's on all of y'all getting your lines.
Yes.
And I'm off camera and I'm giving my speech.
Yes, very good job.
Great.
Camera comes around.
Now it's shooting me.
Yes.
我们先拍你的正反打，镜头对着你们所有人，听你们念台词。是的。而我不在镜头前，我正在发表我的演讲。是的，干得漂亮。太棒了。镜头转过来。现在开始拍我。是的。
And you guys are all off camera.
Sure.
But you're still there because you have lines that you have to say to me while I'm giving
my emotional speech.
You were memorized.
You were and on time.
Yeah.
Do I have to lock eyes with you?
你们都不在镜头前。当然。但你们还在那儿，因为当我在发表情绪化的演讲时，你们还得对我说台词。你们都背熟了台词。而且按时到场。对。我非得跟你四目相对吗？
What do you think?
No.
You don't want it.
No, no, I don't think.
What?
I don't think.
So, here.
Because you're a professional actor.
你觉得呢？不用。你不想。不，不，我觉得不用。什么？我觉得不用。所以，在这儿。因为你是个专业演员。
No, just stop.
I'm sorry for even saying that.
This is your podcast.
You can keep going if you want.
Well, I'm just going to paint a picture for people.
So it's time for my coverage and I'm going through the scene.
Take one.
I'm up there.
不，别说了。真不该说这话。这是你的播客。你想继续就继续吧。好吧，我只是想给大家还原一个画面。所以轮到我的正反打镜头了，我在过剧情。第一条。我站在那儿。
I'm like scanning the room.
Everyone's looking at me.
Sure.
Everyone across the children.
All the people, they're all looking.
Me and the eyes.
Give me my lines that they have to say.
and then I get to you, Bobby.
我环视房间。每个人都在看着我。当然。所有人，还有孩子们。所有人，都在看着我。看着我的眼睛。念出他们必须对我说台词。然后轮到你了，鲍比。
Yes.
And you are looking down.
Like kind of...
Playing Candy Crush.
Into your lap.
But I don't know that.
You just...
You're looking down and I'm like, that's odd.
是的。而你正低着头。有点像……在玩“糖果传奇”。盯着自己的膝盖。但我当时不知道。你只是……你低着头，我心想：这太奇怪了。
No, it's not.
I'm at 896 level and I want to get 897.
Take two.
Okay.
Scans again.
I get to you.
Now I can see you're looking at a phone.
And my first thought was, oh gosh.
不，不是的。我在 896 级，我想升到 897。第二条。好吧。再次扫描。我到你这了。现在我看到你在看手机。我的第一反应是，哦天哪。
He doesn't know his lines.
No.
I thought, oh my gosh, I hope everything's okay.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
Like a text.
Okay.
Can I defend myself?
他不记得台词了。不。我想，哦天哪，我希望一切都好。等等，等等，等等，等等。等等，等等。就像发信息一样。好吧。我能为自己辩解吗？
Like a text.
Like, oh, no, you must have gotten a text.
Angela, may I?
That's, like, super important.
Okay.
Because why else would you be on your phone in the middle of a taping?
It's a group shot.
就像发信息一样。就像，哦，不，你肯定收到信息了。安吉拉，我可以吗？这，超级重要。好吧。因为你在拍摄中途看手机还能有什么别的原因？好吧。这是个群体镜头。
Yeah.
It's a wide.
Okay.
Maybe they're punching in, but I don't know.
But from I remember, it's a wide, so why would you, let me focus on Oliver?
Have you talked to me?
I am looking.
对。是个全景。对。好吧。也许他们在对焦，但我不知道。但据我所能，这是个全景，所以你为什么，让我专注于奥利弗？你跟我说过话吗？我在看。
And so it's very distracting because I'm like, what's happening with, is Bobby okay?
Has someone contacted him?
But you were mad.
happening.
I remember you being mad.
Well, yes, by take four or five, when I realized what I thought is that you were on
Instagram.
I thought you were scrolling Instagram.
所以这非常让人分心，因为我在想，怎么回事，鲍比没事吧？有人联系他吗？但你当时很生气。发生了。我记得你当时很生气。好吧，是的，到了第四或第五条时，当我意识到我以为你在刷 Instagram。我以为你在刷 Instagram。
And so finally I had to go, Bobby.
Yeah.
What the actual fuck dude?
That was bad.
What is happening?
Angela, back me up.
I don't think I can.
所以我最后不得不说，鲍比。对。这到底是什么鬼啊，老兄？太糟糕了。太糟糕了。怎么回事？安吉拉，支持我一下。我觉得我做不到。
Here's the thing.
You know what sucks.
You're a scene partner, right?
So it's like, what I give you, you give me back?
So if you and I were doing a scene solo, you would.
get my attention.
Yeah.
我觉得我做不到。事情是这样的。你知道糟在哪吗。你是搭戏演员，对吧？所以就像，我给你什么，你回馈我什么？所以如果你和我单独拍一场戏，你会。吸引我的注意。对。
Right?
But in a group,
yes, it does.
In a group, Sean?
Come on.
Well, I think you have to know, too.
We did nine years of group scenes,
nine years of conference rooms,
对吧？但在群体戏里，是的，确实。在群体戏里，肖恩？拜托。好吧，我想你也得知道。我们拍了九年的群体戏，九年的会议室，
nine years of Steve Carrell being up in front of everyone,
and us just looking at him.
So Steve would do,
even in his reverse,
give you 100%.
Yes.
Well, I don't know.
九年的史蒂夫·卡瑞尔站在所有人面前，而我们只是看着他。所以史蒂夫会，甚至在他的反打镜头里，也给你百分之百的投入。是的。是的。好吧，我不知道。
See, I'm learning.
Yeah, yeah.
There is a learning.
I mean, this.
But there is a learning.
There's so much to learn.
There is a learning curve.
Yeah.
你看，我在学习。对，对。有一个学习的过程。我是说，这个。但确实有个学习过程。有很多需要学习的地方。有一个学习曲线。对。
But, you know, I was trying to defend myself.
I apologize.
I still, the reason why I brought it up on my pot is because I remember the shame of it.
Oh.
Well, you should release yourself of that.
I mean, you were forgiven moments after it happened.
Yeah.
I wish that Angela took my side every once in a while.
但是，你知道，我当时在试图为自己辩解。我很抱歉。我还是，我之所以在我的播客里提起这件事，是因为我记得当时的羞耻感。哦。好吧，你应该释放自己。我是说，事情发生后不久你就被原谅了。对。我希望安吉拉偶尔能站在我这边。
Yeah.
Anyway, it's comedy.
Let's talk about comedy.
Let's talk about you.
Let's talk about Nimrods.
Okay.
对。不管怎样，这是喜剧。我们来聊聊喜剧。聊聊你。聊聊“笨蛋”（Nimrods）。好吧。聊聊“笨蛋”。聊聊“笨蛋”。
Yeah.
First of all, I have to say one thing.
You're both great in it.
Oh, well, you're hilarious in it.
But Jenna told me, like, from the early days, like, when we did a table read of it, she was like,
Lee was like, I want Bobby.
And you're like, Bobby's got to be in this.
Like, that's how much of an impression you made on her and splitting up together.
对。首先，我得说一件事。你们在里面都很棒。哦，好吧，你在里面太搞笑了。但詹娜告诉我，就像早期的时候，我们在围读剧本的时候，她就说，李说，我想要鲍比。而你说，鲍比必须演这个。就像你给她留下了多深的印象，还有《分道扬镳》。
And Lee.
No, truly.
It's true.
I'm giving you a real compliment.
Really?
Yes.
还有李。不，真的。真的。真的。我在给你一个真诚的赞美。真的吗？是的。是的。
Playing Candy Crush?
No.
Angela?
You are forgiven for that.
Okay.
That is behind you.
All right, now it has.
Yes.
在玩糖果传奇（Candy Crush）？不。安吉拉？你被原谅了。好吧。那已经过去了。好吧，现在已经。是的。
But now we...
I've been thinking about it since.
Clearly, I wasn't holding anything against you because...
Yeah, but I didn't want to bring it up on set.
I mean...
Yeah.
Hey, I apologize for...
No, you know what you should have done is you should have got out Candy Crush.
但现在我们……我从那以后一直在想这件事。很明显，我并没有对你怀恨在心，因为……对，但我不想在片场提起。我是说……对。嘿，我为……不，你知道你当时应该怎么做，你应该拿出“糖果传奇”。
In one take.
That would have been so great.
Did we have a scene?
No, we didn't have a scene.
Yeah, we didn't have a scene.
We're all three in this movie, but not any scenes together.
I know.
Can I be honest with you?
一条过。那可太棒了。我们有一场戏吗？不，我们没有。对，我们没有。我们三个都在这部电影里，但没有对手戏。我知道。我能对你实话实说吗？
Yeah.
I saw the movie up until I came up.
on screen.
Oh.
And then you, do you not like to watch yourself?
I don't.
So I stopped watching.
对。对。我看了这部电影，直到我出现。在屏幕上。哦。然后你，你不喜欢看自己吗？我不喜欢。所以我停下来不看了。
Oh, Bobby, you're so funny in it.
I stopped.
Bobby, you have a line in this movie that my kids.
What is the line?
Yeah, he did.
Oh, yeah.
When you mock him.
All right.
哦，鲍比，你在里面太搞笑了。我停下了。鲍比，你在这部电影里有一句台词，我的孩子们。什么台词？对，他说了。哦，对。当你模仿他的时候。好吧。
Mock one of the kids.
Puberty is hard.
Yeah.
Did you improvise that?
He did.
That's really funny.
模仿其中一个孩子。青春期很难。对。青春期很难。那是你即兴发挥的吗？对。他确实是。太搞笑了。
And then you improvise, yeah, he did.
Yeah, because he had such a squeaky voice.
He did.
I want to say something about the movie.
It feels lived in.
real. Oh, that's a nice compliment. I agree. Do you understand what I'm saying?
I do. Like, when you watch, like, old Spielberg movies, he's good at, like, like, ET and
and Close Encounters of the Third Kind. I love that. Do you? I do. I do. Did you see the movie?
然后你即兴发挥，对，他确实是。对，因为他的声音太尖了。他确实是。我想说点关于这部电影的事。它感觉很有生活气息。真实。哦，这真是个极好的赞美。我同意。你明白我在说什么吗？我明白。就像，你看老斯皮尔伯格的电影，他擅长，比如，比如《E.T.》和《第三类接触》。我太喜欢了。是吗？我喜欢。我喜欢。你看过那部电影吗？
Close Encounters of the Third Kind. Yeah. Yeah. What's it about, Angela? What's about Angela?
What's it about Angela? Oh, my God. First of all, it's Richard Dreyfus. Like, phenomenal performance.
That's enough. All right. That's great. I believe you know. Yeah. But, you know, early Spielberg,
the houses live lived in.
And if it's not lived in, I can't buy into it.
Yeah.
If it doesn't feel real.
You know, sometimes you watch a sitcom or, and everything's so clean.
《第三类接触》。对。对。讲的是什么，安吉拉？讲的是什么，安吉拉？讲的是什么，安吉拉？哦，天哪。首先，那是理查德·德莱费斯。简直是现象级的表演。够了。好吧。太棒了。我相信你知道。对。但是，你知道，早期的斯皮尔伯格，那些房子很有生活气息。如果它没有生活气息，我就无法入戏。对。如果它感觉不真实。你知道，有时候你看情景喜剧，或者，一切都太干净了。
Squeaky.
And you can tell it's on a stage.
And I don't like it.
You know, I like it when it's like lived in is what I'm saying.
The production designer on Nimrods, Adam Riemer, was a genius.
Yes.
Like the home, the garage, all the sets.
I've never seen you in a role like this before as a mom.
一尘不染。你能看出它是在舞台上拍的。我不喜欢那样。你知道，我喜欢那种有生活气息的，这就是我的意思。《笨蛋》的制作设计师亚当·里默是个天才。是的。就像那个家，车库，所有的布景。我以前从来没见过你演过这样的妈妈角色。
It's crazy.
Oh, well, you know.
Well, you were on mom on Splageup together.
Except for that.
Except for that sitcom.
Yeah, yeah.
We're on a sitcom together.
Yeah.
太疯狂了。哦，好吧，你知道。好吧，你在《分道扬镳》里演过妈妈。除了那个。除了那部情景喜剧。对，对。我们一起演过情景喜剧。对。
But to your point, it's a different kind of role.
And, I mean, I could get personal.
Oh, my God.
About it.
Should I?
Yes.
So I shot this movie two weeks after I had my port removed.
after having gone through all my cancer treatment.
但正如你所说，这是一个不同类型的角色。而且，我是说，我可以变得很私密。哦，天哪。关于这个。我应该说吗？是的。所以我拍这部电影时，距离我切除输液港（port）才两周。在我经历了所有的癌症治疗之后。
I had my last infusion, and I'd been kind of like living in my house for like a year,
you know, because I was a little bit on my own personal lockdown,
where my life was just about the treatments.
And I had my last immunotherapy infusion early in 2025,
and then I got my port removed, and two weeks later, I was on set shooting this movie.
And from that experience, I had a kind of heaviness in me because a lot had happened to me in that year.
I had a literal heaviness.
I gained 15 pounds during chemo and during all my treatment.
我做了最后一次输液，然后我差不多在家里生活了一年，你知道的，因为我基本上处于自我隔离状态，我的生活全都是治疗。我在 2025 年初做了最后一次免疫疗法输液，然后我切除了输液港，两周后，我就在片场拍这部电影了。从那段经历中，我内心有一种沉重感，因为那一年发生了很多事情。我有一种字面意义上的沉重感。我在化疗和所有治疗期间重了 15 磅。
And my hair had just started to grow back.
Like I had just enough for this movie.
That's my real hair.
People have asked if it was a wig.
But I had just enough hair.
They kind of like brushed it forward.
They were brilliant.
And it was such a gift to me to take that and put it into this.
我的头发才刚刚开始长出来。就像我刚好有足够的头发来拍这部电影。那是我的真发。人们一直在问那是不是假发。但我刚好有足够的头发。他们把它向前梳理了一下。他们太绝了。对我来说，能把这些经历拿出来并注入到这个角色中，简直是一份厚礼。
part, this part of this mom who also has a real heaviness to her. She's a widow. She's raising two
teen boys on her own. And she's a little bit at the end of her rope, but trying to be kind of optimistic
at the same time. I mean, I love this woman. And I don't think this is a part that I would have
been offered or asked to play had I not gone through everything I went through. Because I didn't have
it in me. I didn't have it in my body. I didn't have it in my toolkit. Like, I just didn't have it.
And so for me, this movie is really, really special because I got to take something hard that happened to me and I got to put it into art, which is kind of just the best thing ever.
And it was really healing for me.
So thank you for saying that.
这个角色，这个单亲妈妈的角色也有着沉重的内心。她是个寡妇。她独自抚养两个十几岁的男孩。她有点走投无路，但同时又试图保持乐观。我是说，我爱这个女人。而且我认为，如果我没有经历过我所经历的一切，我是不会得到这个角色或被邀请去演它的。因为我以前没有这种状态。我的身体里没有。我的工具箱里没有。我就是没有。所以对我来说，这部电影真的非常非常特别，因为我把发生在我身上的痛苦经历转化成了艺术，这可以说是最棒的事情了。这对我来说真的很治愈。所以谢谢你这么说。
It really means a lot.
I just, I'm sorry.
Oh.
I remember you telling me on set, it was devastating.
Yeah.
I had no idea.
这真的意义重大。我只是，我很抱歉。哦。我记得你在片场跟我说过，那太毁灭性了。对。我完全不知道。对。对。
I'm so sorry.
But you're...
I'm in full remission.
Yes.
Yeah.
And now it's like, it's good.
God, it's weird to say it was a good thing that happened to me.
But it was definitely one of those moments in life.
我很抱歉。但你……我完全缓解了。是的。对。现在感觉，很好。天哪，说那是一件发生在我身上的好事感觉好奇怪。但它绝对是生命中的那些时刻之一。
It was a before and after, you know?
There's like, there was my life before and now there's my life after.
And my life after, it's been transformative.
I can't, yeah.
But I mean, I feel like you must have had before and after with getting sober.
Yeah.
Right?
这是一个“之前”和“之后”的分水岭，你知道吗？就像，有我之前的生活，现在有我之后的生活。而我之后的生活，是具有变革性的。我不能，对。但我的意思是，我觉得你戒酒后也一定经历过“之前”和“之后”。对吧？对。
I mean, that's a very before-after.
I think it's different, though.
I don't think I was as scared as you might have been.
You know, I always thought, you know, I can always get sober or whatever.
I mean, that's all I needed to do is to get sober, right?
But you have no control over what you had, you know, so it must be just terrifying.
Yeah.
You know, truly, it's really hard to watch someone you love go through something and you don't know how to help them.
我是说，那是非常明显的“之前-之后”。不过我觉得有所不同。我觉得我可能没有你那么害怕。你知道，我总是想，你知道，我随时都可以戒酒什么的。我的意思是，我需要做的全部事情就是戒酒，对吧？但你对你得的病没有任何控制权，你知道，所以那一定非常可怕。对。你知道，真的，看著你爱的人经历痛苦而你却不知道该如何帮助他们，这真的很艰难。
Yeah.
And so, and anything you do to try to help.
doesn't feel like enough, you know?
And so you just try to show up, you know?
And so even as you were saying all that,
it was so great to watch this movie
and have seen you through that
and on the other side and getting to create.
对。所以，你为了帮忙而做的任何事情。都感觉不够，你知道吗？所以你只能努力去陪伴，你知道吗？所以甚至当你在说所有这些的时候，看著这部电影，看著你经历这一切并走到另一边开始创作，感觉真的太棒了。
And I love the character
and I love the movie that Lee made.
It's really great.
I'm excited for people to see it.
Well, lady, you took me to get my port removed
because Lee had started shooting the movie.
It was a weird thing for us too
because he'd been with me the whole journey
我喜欢这个角色，我也喜欢李拍的这部电影。真的很棒。我很兴奋大家能看到它。好吧，美女，你带我去切除输液港的，因为当时李已经开始拍电影了。对我们来说这也是一件奇怪的事，因为他陪我经历了整个过程。
and now his movie gets greenlit
in like the last two months of my treatment.
And he had to be away.
And so Angela took me to get my port removed.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
Which was amazing because she's the best BFF ever.
Yeah, we're family.
而现在他的电影在我的治疗期的最后两个月左右获批立项了。他必须离开。所以安吉拉带我去切除了输液港。对。嗯嗯。这太棒了，因为她是史上最好的闺蜜。对，我们是一家人。
Yeah.
That's amazing.
So you take care of each other.
I don't think I have anyone like that in my life.
Maybe I'm a girlfriend.
I'm sure you're a girlfriend.
Yeah, maybe I'm a girlfriend.
对。对。太棒了。所以你们互相照顾。我觉得我生命中没有这样的人。也许我有女朋友。我确信你是个女朋友。对，也许我是个女朋友。
Your girlfriend.
She would take you to L-AX, right?
I don't think so, but I think that she would, for port.
I don't know, yeah.
Yeah.
But Santino, I don't know.
Andrew Santino, I don't know.
I'm not sure Lee would drive me to LAX.
你的女朋友。她会带你去洛杉矶国际机场（LAX），对吧？我不这么认为，但我认为她会，为了切输液港。我不知道，对。对。但桑蒂诺，我不知道。安德鲁·桑蒂诺，我不知道。我不确定李会不会开车送我去洛杉矶国际机场。
He'll see me through cancer treatment and I'm not sure he's dropping me at L.A.
Yeah.
Or picking me up.
For people listening, L.A.X is the worst airport to try to talk.
It's the worst.
Burbank, yes.
Burbank?
Yes, for sure.
他会陪我度过癌症治疗期，但我不敢确定他会不会把我送到洛杉矶机场。对。或者去接我。对于正在收听的听客来说，洛杉矶国际机场是出了名最难交谈的机场。是最差的。伯班克，是的。伯班克？是的，绝对的。
He's taking me to Burbank.
It's fine.
All the time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I would go to the Long Beach Airport.
I would do that.
Yes, yes, yes.
But LACs, man.
他会带我去伯班克。没问题。一直都这样。对，对，对。我会去长滩机场。我会那样做。是的，是的，是的。但洛杉矶国际机场，天哪。
Wait, back to Nimrods.
Yes, of course.
Will you tell us.
how you got the role.
I got a call from my agent goes, they said you were offered this part.
And I said, yes, immediately.
There you go.
Because I knew Billy from a long time ago during my mad TV days.
等等，回到“笨蛋”。对，当然。你能告诉我们你是怎么得到这个角色的吗。我接到经纪人的电话，他说，他们说这个角色邀请了你。我说，好，马上。这就对了。因为我很早以前在《疯狂电视》（MADtv）时期就认识比利了。
Billy Joe Armstrong from Green Day, producer of this movie.
Yeah.
And I used to hang out with him.
I run into them.
I hang out with it.
Back then, LA was different.
Like, I remember going to Baja Fresh and then running into the strokes.
You know what I mean?
比利·乔·阿姆斯特朗（Billy Joe Armstrong），来自绿日乐队，这部电影的制片人。对。我以前经常跟他混在一起。我碰过他们。我跟他们一起玩。那时候，洛杉矶可不一样。就像，我记得去巴哈新鲜墨西哥餐厅（Baja Fresh），然后碰到了鼓击乐队（The Strokes）。你知道我的意思吗？
You just run into people.
That's so cool.
Yeah.
What was your first neighborhood in L.A.?
It was.
It was North Hollywood, then Silver Lake, then West Hollywood, then Hollywood, and now Studio City.
Yeah, so I've been around.
Where were you in West Hollywood?
你就会偶遇各种人。太酷了。对。你在洛杉矶的第一个社区是哪里？是。是北好莱坞，然后是银湖，然后是西好莱坞，然后是好莱坞，现在是工作室城。对，所以我到处都住过。你住在西好莱坞的哪里？
I lived above the comedy store.
Polly owned it.
Are you serious?
Oh, yeah.
What was that like?
It was terrible.
It was a human nightmare.
That seems really difficult.
我住在喜剧商店（Comedy Store）楼上。波利（Polly）是老板。真的吗？哦，对。那是什么体验？太糟糕了。简直是一场人类噩梦。听起来真的很艰难。
I would come home and be on my bed sleeping.
Oh, my gosh.
Polly, sure.
Yeah.
Dude, I own the house, brah.
Right?
I could sleep wherever I want to sleep.
I go, I pay rent.
我回到家，在床上睡觉。哦，天哪。波利，当然。对。老兄，这房子是我的，兄弟。对吧？我想在哪里睡就在哪里睡。我说，我交房租。
Dude?
I pay rent.
But anyway, so I moved out of there because the house is falling off a cliff, they said.
The comedy store?
No, no.
So the house above the comedy store, the inspector came in and goes, you could die in here.
And then I remember a bunch of comics were like, just buy a house.
You can buy it.
老兄？我交房租。但不管怎样，我从那里搬出来了，因为他们说房子快从悬崖上掉下去了。喜剧商店？不，不。所以喜剧商店楼上的房子，检查员进来后说，你可能会死在这里。然后我记得一堆喜剧演员说，买栋房子吧。你能买得起。
So I bought my first house.
Nice.
After that, yeah.
Which is freeing in many ways.
It feels grown up.
Yeah.
And back then you could afford it.
Now you can't.
所以我买了我人生第一栋房子。不错。在那之后，对。这在很多方面都是一种解放。感觉成熟了。对。而且那时候你还买得起。现在买不起了。
No.
Now it's crazy. Yeah, now you can't. But yeah, now it's crazy.
Okay, wait, there's one thing I have to tell you. I really want to come see your stage show.
No. What do you mean stage show? Stand up?
Yes.
Dude, yeah, it's just stand-up. I have a special coming out on Hulu in November.
Okay. It's my first hour special.
I know, it's your first hour special. That's amazing.
不。现在太疯狂了。对，现在买不起了。但是，等等，有件事我必须告诉你。我真的很想去看你的舞台秀。不。你什么意思，舞台秀？单口喜剧？对。老兄，对，就是单口喜剧。我有一个专场将于 11 月在 Hulu 上线。好吧。这是我的第一个一小时专场。我知道，这是你的第一个一小时专场。太棒了。
For what company? Hulu.
Okay, good.
I was listening.
Okay.
But my sons love you. And they were so tickled that I was meeting you today.
They just can't believe that you're in the podcast.
Were they? Are they here?
No, they're at home.
为哪家公司？Hulu。好的，很好。我有在听。好吧。但我的儿子们很喜欢你。他们对今天能见到你感到非常兴奋。他们简直不敢相信你上了这个播客。是吗？他们在这里吗？不，他们在家里。
Okay.
But my nephew...
You're a big deal.
You met my nephew on the set of Nimrod.
Yes.
He flew out because he wanted to see a couple days of filming.
It's because of you.
Was I nice to him?
好吧。但我的侄女……你可是个大人物。你在《笨蛋》片场见过我侄女。是的。她飞过来是因为她想看几天拍摄。全是因为你。我对她好吗？
Yes, very.
Oh, because I'm a nice person.
Yes.
Yeah, sure.
Exactly.
He was so excited to meet you and that was so nice of you.
Stage show?
I sometimes get phrases wrong, just a little bit.
是的，非常好。哦，因为我是个好人。是的。没错。正是如此。她很高兴能见到你，你人真的太好了。舞台秀？我有时候会把短语说错，就一点点。
I want to brag on you.
I'm going to talk about what a nice person you are.
I hope this won't be embarrassing to you.
I don't think it would be.
Okay, so there's a...
young guy in this movie, Ryan Faust.
Love him.
He plays the drummer in the young punk band.
我想夸夸你。我要聊聊你是一个多么好的人。我希望这不会让你觉得尴尬。我觉得应该不会。好吧，这部电影里有个……年轻小伙子，瑞恩·福斯特。我很喜欢他。他演那个年轻朋克乐队的鼓手。
Yeah, I understand.
He's so great.
I'm letting other people know.
Uh-oh.
This guy, first of all, he's just so good in the movie.
He's so funny.
He's so good in the movie.
So good in the movie.
对，我明白。他太棒了。我正让其他人也知道呢。噢噢。这家伙，首先，他在电影里表现得太棒了。他太搞笑了。他在电影里表现太棒了。在电影里表现太棒了。
And he had to learn to play the drums because he's really playing.
I think they all had to learn, right?
Yes.
Well, Kyler Kaufman already knew how to play guitar.
But yes, Mason Tames had to learn to play guitar.
and then Ryan had to learn drums.
And he was really dedicated.
Yeah, because he's a student of acting.
而且他不得不学打鼓，因为他是真在打。我想他们当时都得学，对吧？是的。嗯，凯勒·考夫曼本来就会弹吉他。不过是的，梅森·泰姆斯不得不学弹吉他，然后瑞恩不得不学打鼓。他真的很投入。对，因为他是学表演的。
Yeah.
He wants to immerse himself into the role and not look fake.
And that's what I love about Ryan is that he's brave and he commits.
And I know what the compliment is.
You do.
And I don't think it's a compliment.
And I don't think it's me being a nice guy.
It's just that I like bravery.
对。他想让自己沉浸在角色中，而不是显得很假。这就是我喜欢瑞恩的地方，他很勇敢，而且全心投入。我知道你想夸什么了。你知道的。而且我不觉得这算恭维。我也不觉得这是因为我是个好人。我只是喜欢勇敢的人。
Mm-hmm.
And Ryan said to me on set, I want to try stand-up.
Is that what you're going to get at?
Yeah.
You said you write a set.
let's set a date and I'll let you open for me.
Yeah.
That's what I said.
嗯哼。瑞恩在片场对我说，我想尝试单口喜剧。你是想说这个吗？对。你说你写了一套段落，我们定个日子，我让你给我暖场。对。我是这么说的。
Yeah.
I mean, that's fucking cool.
And he did it a bunch of times.
I know.
Yeah, and he was very good.
And that kind of like mentorship, like that is so cool.
That is so cool.
对。对。我的意思是，这太他妈酷了。而且他真的去演了好多次。我知道。对，而且他演得非常好。这种像导师一样的提携，太酷了。真的太酷了。
Yeah, I've done that a lot.
But it's like, I just love people that are brave and that walk through fear.
And I'm willing to hold someone's hand to do that.
You know, but yeah, I'm not one of those guys that are like completely jealous or I want people
to make it.
That's a beautiful thing.
Because it's in, I mean,
you know,
对，我以前经常这么做。但我的意思是，我就是喜欢勇敢、敢于面对恐惧的人。我愿意牵着别人的手去做到这一点。你知道的，但是，是的，我不是那种完全嫉妒别人或者不想让别人成功的人。那是件很美好的事。因为从某种意义上讲，我是说，你知道的，
in order to achieve success,
you have to help people
achieve the success, I believe.
And people probably helped you.
Yeah.
They did.
为了取得成功，你必须帮助别人取得成功，我相信这一点。而且以前肯定也有人帮助过你。对。是的。他们确实帮过。
I think the Shore family was very vital,
you know.
Polly's mom owned the comedy store.
And she saw me do open mic,
and then she saw me open for her son,
and she made me a paid regular,
and I moved to L.A.
This is in San Diego.
我觉得肖尔家族非常关键，你知道的。波莉的妈妈拥有喜剧商店。她看我做了开放话筒秀，然后看我给她儿子暖场，就把我变成了带薪的常驻演员，于是我搬到了洛杉矶。这是在圣迭戈。
And so they really helped.
And a lot of,
comics helped, you know, and dice clay helped in a weird way, you know. People really kind of
pulled me up by my sleeves. Is that the term? I don't know. But people took a chance on you.
Right? People helped you, no? Of course. Yeah, of course. And this is the thing. Like, this is,
I love that about our industry when you find those other people who are like that. I believe there's
enough room for everyone. Yeah. And if you've got a talent, we've got room for you. Yes. I do believe
that too. And it's like, I'll tell you something, I was plagued by jealousy early on in my career.
所以他们真的帮了忙。很多喜剧演员也帮了忙，你知道的，戴斯·克莱也以一种奇怪的方式帮了忙，你知道的。人们真的可以说是把我拉扯起来的。是这个词吗？我不知道。但人们确实给了你机会，对吧？人们帮助过你，对吗？当然。对，当然。这就是重点。就像，我喜欢我们行业的一点就是，当你找到其他这样的人时。我相信蛋糕够大，每个人都有份。对。如果你有才华，我们这里就有你的位置。是的。我也这么认为。而且，这么说吧，我职业生涯早期曾深受嫉妒心的困扰。
I had to have a moment where I was like, what about me? And then, you know, about a year of that,
I was like, this is not who I am. And it's painful to live in that. Yeah. To live in that.
You know, I have to admit that, you know, but yeah, I'm completely different now. Yeah, abundant universe.
You kind of come to that. And I think if you get older. I think that to survive,
in this biz.
And also, can I just say this too,
you're adapting to the transitions of show business.
Like for me, it's like I saw the writing on the wall a little bit.
我曾经历过这样一个时刻，当时我在想：那我呢？然后，你知道的，大约过了一年这种生活，我觉得：这根本不是真正的我。活在那种状态里太痛苦了。是的。活在那种状态里。你知道的，我必须承认这一点，你知道的，不过，是的，我现在完全不同了。是的，这是一个充满无限可能的世界。你最终会明白这一点的。而且我想随着你年纪变大。我认为要想在这个行业生存下去。还有，我能顺便说一句吗，你正在适应娱乐圈的转型。对我而言，就好像我提前看到了一些苗头。
I was like, I had to create my own thing.
Yeah.
Right?
And so you created this thing.
It's your own thing.
And it's like you're adapting because it's like,
I think that obviously it's transitioning into something else.
We don't know really what it is with the emergence of AI and other things.
我觉得我必须创造属于我自己的东西。对吧？所以你创造了这个。这是你自己的东西。这就好比你在适应时代，因为很显然，它正在向其他方向转型。随着人工智能和其他事物的出现，我们其实并不清楚它最终会变成什么样。
But it's like,
we're adapting to what it is.
So it's like for you to survive this long is amazing.
Yeah.
You know, you're survivors.
Well, thanks for saying that.
Yeah, you have to be able to adapt, right?
Yeah.
但这就好比，我们在适应它原本的样子。所以你能在这个行业存活这么久，真的很了不起。对。你知道的，你们都是幸存者。好吧，谢谢你这么说。对，你得有适应能力，对吧？对。
So what do you want to do next?
I'm going to retire in three years.
Is that true?
Yeah.
Retire from what?
Everything.
From podcasting, comedy, and acting?
那你接下来想做什么？我打算三年后退休。真的假的？对。从什么行业退休？所有行业。从播客、喜剧和表演？所有。
You're just going to piece out.
Where are you going?
I want to go to Hawaii.
Oh, yeah.
And just buy a little place.
Amazing.
And just farm.
Yes.
你这就打算拍拍屁股走人了？你要去哪？我想去夏威夷。哦，真的。然后买个小地方。太棒了。然后种种地。对。
But when I'm never going to do it, am I?
Why not?
Because I say it, but I don't think I will.
This is a beautiful idea.
Don't you feel compelled to be artistic and creative, though?
Like, where will you take that energy in the Hawaii farming chapter?
Okay, so here's what I'll do.
This is my plan.
但我大概永远也不会真正去干吧，对吗？为什么不呢？因为我嘴上这么说，但我觉得我不会去。这倒是个美好的想法。难道你内心没有对艺术和创作的渴望吗？到了夏威夷种地的阶段，你打算把这股精力往哪儿使呢？好吧，那我告诉你我是怎么想的。这是我的计划。
Okay.
I'll still do my own solo podcast in Hawaii, but more ranting and raving about things.
And then I'll still do local stand-up in Hawaii.
Okay.
Yeah.
And then I think that'll fill, you know, but it's like...
好吧。好吧。我还是会在夏威夷做我自己的个人播客，不过内容会更多是对各种事情的疯狂吐槽。好吧。然后我还是会在夏威夷当地表演单口喜剧。好吧。对。然后我觉得这就能填补……你知道的，不过……
Yeah, but I think that I've been chasing this since I was 23 years old.
Yeah.
And it never seems like I made it.
You made it.
I know, but it doesn't feel like it.
I know.
Okay.
I want to unpack this.
对，但我觉得我从23岁起就一直在追逐这个。对。而且感觉我好像从来没有真正成功过。你已经成功了。我知道，但感觉上并没有。我知道。好吧。我想好好剖析一下这个。
What do you expect making it would feel like?
Well, can I be honest with you?
Of course.
This is the first movie Nimrods where I was in the opening credits.
Yeah.
So thank you for that experience.
I've done a lot of movies before, but I was always in the end credits.
你觉得成功了应该是什么感觉？好吧，我能和你说实话吗？当然可以。这是我第一次参演电影《野蛮人》（Nimrods），而且我的名字出现在了开场字幕里。对。所以谢谢你带给我这种体验。对。我以前演过很多电影，但我的名字总是在片尾字幕里。
And 52 names would come down.
And they would say, Bobby Lee, Ken Park, but like no one's watching.
My point is that I've been in this business for so long.
I've been on sitcoms and series regular.
So God bless America.
But my point is this is that this is the first movie where I was in the opening credits.
You're on the movie poster too.
I know.
然后52个名字滚屏而过。他们会念：鲍比·李，肯·帕克，但根本没人看。我的重点是，我在这个行业待了这么久。我演过情景喜剧，当过剧集常规演员。所以感谢上帝。但我的重点是，这是我第一部名字出现在开场字幕里的电影。你还在电影海报上呢。我知道。
My point, though, being that I'm grateful for what I've had,
but it's like this chasing thing.
I think I'm done with.
Well, that's a real thing to listen to.
I'm with you.
I feel tired of just...
Chasing.
不过我的意思是，我很感激我所拥有的一切，但这种追逐的过程，我想我受够了。嗯，这确实是肺腑之言。我懂你。我厌倦了只是……追逐。追逐。
I don't want to be a hamster on the wheel.
I've been telling Jenna that.
And I'm happy.
And I think everything I've done is enough for me.
Really?
Happiness is a warm.
Yes, it is.
I don't know why I did this.
我不想当转轮里的仓鼠。我一直对珍娜这么说。而且我很幸福。我觉得我做过的一切对现在的我来说已经足够了。真的吗？幸福就是温暖的……对，确实如此。我不知道我为什么要这么做。
I'm sorry.
Can you tell us more about Mad TV?
What was that like?
But you understand.
When I was on Mad TV, I'd never take an acting class.
I've never been on TV.
I didn't know what a jib camera was or a mark was or any of that.
Yeah.
我很抱歉。你能跟我们多讲讲《疯狂电视》（Mad TV）吗？那段经历是怎样的？但你能理解的。我在《疯狂电视》的时候，从没上过表演课。我从来没上过电视。我不知道什么是摇臂摄像机，什么是定点标记，什么都不知道。对。
So you're learning how to do TV.
I was an open micer, like doing just like little rooms and like empty rooms.
No one knew who I was.
And then all of a sudden, you know, I auditioned.
It was a cattle call pretty much.
And then it came down to me and Taryn Kill him.
That's crazy.
Wow.
所以你是在边干边学怎么拍电视。我以前是个开放话筒演员，只在一些小房间里表演，比如空荡荡的房间。没人知道我是谁。然后突然有一天，你知道的，我去试镜了。那几乎是一场海选。最后剩下我和泰伦·基勒（Taran Killam）。太疯狂了。哇。
And they hired both of us.
He was on Matt TV before he was on SNO.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. And then all of a sudden, I'm on a show and I don't know how to do it.
Like, I just didn't know how to do it.
How old were you?
I was 30.
30, yeah.
然后他们把我们俩都录用了。他去《周六夜现场》（SNL）之前就在《疯狂电视》里。对，对。然后突然之间，我就上了一个节目，而我根本不知道该怎么拍。真的就是不知道该怎么拍。你当时多大？我30岁。30岁，对。
I was 30 when I booked the office.
Yeah.
And I was like, how do you do this?
You know, I did some commercials, but it's like, those are different.
Yeah.
Because, you know, sometimes when you're a commercial, it's like, you'll see somebody
running by you and you just do a facial expression.
Those I can do.
我接到《办公室》（The Office）的时候30岁。对。当时我在想：这到底怎么演啊？你知道的，我拍过一些广告，但那完全是两码事。对。因为你知道，有时候拍广告，你会看到有人从你旁边跑过，然后你只要做一个面部表情就行。那种我还会。
Right.
But it's like, you know, anything with like substantial lines, you know, it would be
nerve-wracking for me.
Because back then also, there was no teleprompter.
Yeah.
So if I played Connie Chung and I had to do a monologue, it was literally learn the whole thing.
Is that right?
Oh, yeah.
对。但你知道的，任何有实质性台词的戏，对我来说都压力山大。因为在那个年代，也没有提词器。对。所以如果我扮演康妮·陈（Connie Chung），要演一段独白，那就真的是得把整段话全背下来。是这样的吗？哦，对。
Wow.
And you're looking in the camera and you're like, you have to memorize a page worth of things.
And I remember at one time, one of the producers came up to me and she held my hands.
And she said, just breathe.
It was in front of a live audience, too.
I don't know.
I never did.
哇。哇。你要看着摄像机，背下一整页的台词。我记得有一次，有个制片人走到我面前，握住我的双手。她说：放轻松，深呼吸。当时那还是在现场观众面前。我不知道。我从来没……
in high school maybe did some plays, but, you know, I was in The Sound of Music.
I played Kirk, whatever, or Kurt, whatever his name is, but I played Huckleberry Finn.
Yeah.
Why you laughing?
I don't know.
I just, can I just say something.
I wish I could go back and see you in these productions.
So when Fraulein Maria calls us for the first thing coming down this era, I was in high school,
高中时大概演过一些戏剧，但，你知道的，我演过《音乐之声》。我演的是库尔克，随便什么，或者库尔特，管他叫什么名字呢，我还演过哈克贝利·芬恩。对。你笑什么？我不知道。我只是，我能说句话吗？我真希望能回到过去看你演这些剧。当玛丽亚修女叫我们下楼时，我当时在读高中，
and I was the only Korean kid in the cast.
And every time the audience would see me, the audience would laugh.
Oh, no, that's terrible.
And then I asked the director of, you know, you're in high school, you're like,
can't we change the lines?
They go, what do you mean?
I go, just to justify why I'm there.
So like, I'm Kirk, I'm adopted.
我是演员阵容里唯一的韩国小孩。每次观众看到我，观众都会笑。哦，不，那太糟糕了。然后我问导演，你知道的，你还在上高中，就会问：我们不能改改台词吗？他们说：你什么意思？我说：就为了合理解释我为什么会出现在那儿。比如，我是库尔特，我是收养的。
Or something.
You're like, so long, farewell, and Vita say goodnight.
Yeah.
I'm Kirk.
I'm adopted.
Yeah.
Something like that, right?
It's like even playing Huckleberry Finn, it's like we have to justify why I'm Korean in the
或者诸如此类的。你就会说：再见，晚安，维达（Von Trapp）一家晚安。对。我是库尔特。我是收养的。对。类似这样，对吧？就好像连演哈克贝利·芬恩一样，我们都得解释为什么在那个时期的
South in this time period.
Yeah, that's where things have changed, I feel like.
Yeah.
For our kids.
I couldn't even believe I even got those roles.
You know what they're like, anyway.
南方会有我这么个韩国人。对，我觉得现在情况已经变了。对。对。对。为了我们的孩子们。我甚至不敢相信自己当时能得到那些角色。反正你知道他们是什么样的。
So I was scared, but I'm fine now.
Yeah.
Could I tell you what they did to me at Matt TV?
What?
They made a compilation of my bad table reads.
Do you do bad table reads?
I do.
You're not good at a table read?
所以我当时很害怕，但现在我没事了。对。我能告诉你他们在《疯狂电视》里对我做了什么吗？什么？他们把我读剧本时的糟糕表现剪成了一个合集集锦。你读剧本时表现也很糟吗？我确实很糟。你很不擅长围读剧本吗？
I hate them.
Table reads are intimidating, though.
They are.
I think you kill it.
No, I don't.
She does.
she'll get like a guest spot on a show.
我讨厌围读。不过围读剧本确实挺吓人的。确实挺吓人的。我觉得你表现得很棒。不，我没有。她很棒。她确实很棒。她会在一部剧里客串一个角色，
Yeah.
And she'll do the table read.
And then they'll give her more lines the next day because she crushed the table read.
Wow.
That's Angela Kinsey.
She's always, no, it's true lady.
They're always like, expanded.
对。然后她去参加剧本围读。接着第二天他们就会给她加更多台词，因为她在围读时惊艳全场。哇。那是安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）。哇。他们总是，不，真的，伙计。他们总是说：戏份加重了。
You're like, oh, we wrote you another whole scene.
They take scenes away from me.
The table read.
Yeah.
This is the truth.
I've literally had people go, we're not doing that scene.
And you go, oh, why?
But I know why.
你就会想：哦，我们为你多写了整整一场戏。他们总是从我这儿删戏。在剧本围读的时候。对。这是真的。我真的遇到过有人对我说：我们不拍那场戏了。然后你会问：哦，为什么？但我心里其实明白为什么。
Because I fucked up the scene before.
It's hard when you're guest starring.
It is guess.
Because people have been working together for maybe sometimes years.
Yeah.
And you're like a new person.
And sometimes they're not even that nice to you.
因为我把之前的戏搞砸了。客串演出本来就很不容易。确实是。因为大家可能已经一起合作过好几年了。是啊。对啊。而你就像是个新人。有时他们甚至对你没那么友好。
Here's the thing.
I'm okay to table read, but I'm horrible at the chit-chat small talk once we're on set.
When you're a guest star?
Yeah.
Because I assume like if someone's like, how are you?
How is your day?
Jenna knows I'll just say, well, here's the thing.
I think a rat is eating.
事情是这样的。围读剧本我没问题，但一旦上了片场，让我跟人闲聊打发时间我就抓瞎了。当你是客串演员时？对啊。因为我以为如果有人问，你好吗？你今天过得怎么样？珍娜知道我只会说，嗯，事情是这样的。我觉得有只老鼠在吃。
the inside of my car.
This is true.
But I will tell this person who's just like an AD who just is wanting to like walk right past me.
But it's a funny thing to say.
But it's just what's happening.
Do you know what I mean?
Yeah.
And so those are inside thoughts.
我车里的内饰。这是真的。但我会把这事告诉一个只是想从我身边的助理导演。但这话说出来挺逗的。但它就是正在发生的事。你知道我的意思吗？对啊。所以这些都是内心独白。
Yes.
And then I watch the person's eyes glaze over of like, oh my God.
I told Sarah Jessica Parker I had foot fungi.
Did you really?
You were sitting there in, she was doing crosswords or something as they do.
Oh, yes.
You were so good.
on that show.
没错。然后我就看着对方的眼神变得呆滞，心想，天哪。我曾告诉莎拉·杰西卡·帕克我有脚气。真的吗？你当时就坐在那儿，她正在填字游戏什么的，他们经常这样。哦，是的。你在那部剧里表现太棒了。
No, I wasn't.
And just like that.
I don't think I was, but thank you.
Stop it!
But yeah, I remember like doing that.
Making conversation.
Yeah, but it was like my, like I'm around a lot of comedians, you know, and she was super
nice.
不，我才没有。还有《华尔街日报》那一出。我觉得我没有，但谢谢你。别这样！不过，对，我记得我当时那样做过。找话题聊天。对，但就像我的，因为我身边有很多喜剧演员，你知道的，她人超级好。
I love her.
Of course.
But I didn't know what to bring up.
Can I tell you my super cringedged story.
Tell me.
Being a co-star.
It was not even a guest star.
Not a recurring.
我爱她。当然。但我不知道该聊点什么。我能跟你讲讲我那超级尴尬的故事吗？讲给我听听。作为一个特约演员。甚至还算不上客串演员。也不是常驻演员。
What's a difference?
Okay, you were recurring on and just like that.
You were in several.
episodes, but not every episode.
You're in many episodes, though.
That's recurring.
That's great.
You're like kind of part of the cast.
有什么区别？好吧，你当时在《就这样》里是常驻演员。你演了好几集。但不是每集都有。不过你演了很多集。那就算常驻。那挺厉害的。你有点像是剧组的一员了。
What's guest starring?
Guestar is when you have like one week, one week.
One whole week.
You probably have multiple scenes.
You have a significant, like some part of the story involves you.
And then co-star is usually also referred to as like five and under.
You have five or less lines.
Okay, but I had a co-star role on a comedy.
那什么是客串演员？客串是指你演大概一周，就一周。整整一周。你可能会拍好几场戏。你有一个很重要的角色，比如说故事的一部分跟你有关。然后特约演员通常也被称为“五句话及以下”的角色。你只有五句或更少的台词。好吧，不过我曾在一部喜剧里演过特约角色。
I had five or less lines and it was on post office.
pre-office.
Oh, what the Nets?
It was Spin City, the Charlie Sheen years.
So I'm in this scene.
So it's Charlie Sheen, Heather Locklear,
Scott Wolfe, and Vanessa Marcell.
So all of these people are like household names,
我只有不到五句台词，那是在《邮局》拍的。前办公室时期。哦，哪家网？是《政界小人物》，查理·辛在的那几年。所以我得拍这场戏。有查理·辛、海瑟·洛克莱尔、斯科特·沃尔夫和瓦妮萨·马塞尔。所以所有这些人都家喻户晓，
and I am hired to play their waitress.
But I'm new.
This is my first speaking role on a television show.
You were nervous.
I was in hair and makeup with Heather Locklear.
She was so nice to me.
and then we get on set and we rehearse, but now we're waiting for notes.
And the four of them start talking.
而我被雇来演他们的女服务员。但我是个新人。这是我第一次在电视剧里有台词。你当时很紧张。我和海瑟·洛克莱尔一起在化妆间。她对人太好了。然后我们去片场排练，但现在我们在等导演给意见。他们四个人开始聊天了。
And oh my God, they're talking about like all these tabloid stories and they know if something's
true or not true.
They're gossiping.
And you're listening in.
I'm listening, but I don't know where I'm supposed to be like, am I part of this group
or am I not part of this group?
You're not.
哦，天哪，他们聊的全是各种八卦小报的故事，他们知道什么事是真的，什么事是假的。他们在八卦。他们在八卦。而你在旁边偷听。我在听，但我不知道自己该怎么反应，我是该融入这个圈子，还是不该融入这个圈子？你当然不该。
And I didn't.
And so I, before I knew, because she,
She was so nice to me in the trailer.
Heather Lachlager.
I think I'm part of the group.
You think you're a pal.
What are the signs that you're part of the group?
Because she was nice to you?
我没有融入。所以，在我明白过来之前，因为她，她在化妆间里对我太好了。海瑟·洛克莱尔。我以为自己是他们圈子里的人。你觉得自己成了好哥们。你凭什么觉得你是圈子里的人？就因为她对你好？
Because she was nice to me in hair and makeup.
Yeah.
And we're standing there.
And I'm, when you say nice, she said, hello.
She also asked if I wanted some cheese.
Oh, that's good.
That's really nice.
She's like, I want.
因为她在化妆间对我很友好。对啊。我们就站在那儿。当你觉得她好时，她说了声“你好”。她还问我想不想吃点奶酪。哦，那挺不错的。人真的很好。她说，我想。
BFF.
Yeah, BFF.
Yeah.
Someone came in and said, does anybody want a snack?
She's like, oh my God, could we get like some cheese and crackers and stuff?
She's like, do you want some cheese and crackers if you share them?
What a sweetheart.
Right?
做死党。对，死党。对。有人进来问，有人要零食吗？她说，哦，天哪，我们能来点奶酪饼干之类的东西吗？她说，你要是分点给别人，你想不想要奶酪饼干？真是个甜心。对吧？
And they're like, I'll take cheese and crackers.
Sure.
No.
So anyway, I can't move.
I'm not allowed to leave the set.
I have to stand next to the table while we're waiting for our notes.
And they're talking and I think I'm in the conversation.
And so I chime in.
他们就说，我要奶酪饼干。当然。好吧。总之，我不能动。我不准离开片场。在等导演意见的时候，我必须站在桌子旁边。他们在聊天，我以为我也在谈话中。于是我插了句话。
Oh, no.
Instinctually no.
Do you feel it?
I feel it right now.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Bobby, you know how you're still carrying around the phone incident from splitting up together.
I carry around my chime in.
哦，不。哦，不。本能地觉得不妙。你感受到了吗？我此刻都感受到了。不，不，不，不，不，不。鲍比，你知道你为什么一直对之前分手时那个电话事件耿耿于怀吗？我也对自己在。
on Spin City.
Wow.
I still in my body.
Can you tell me what the reaction was?
Like, do you remember what?
It was crickets.
It was silence.
《政界小人物》里插话的事耿耿于怀。哇。我全身都记忆犹新。你能告诉我当时大家的反应吗？比如，你还记得吗？全场鸦雀无声。一片死寂。一片死寂。
And then Heather Locklear broke the silence with like a completely kind like gesture, like a kind of like, ha, huh?
You know, like.
But imagine them.
But imagine them when you got the office.
Well.
And then they look back and they went, you know what?
Hey, we should have been nicer to her.
No, it's not that they were.
然后海瑟·洛克莱尔打破了沉默，做了一个非常友善的举动，大概就是那种，哈，哼？你知道的，就像那样。但想象一下他们。但当你接下《办公室》时想象一下他们的反应。好吧。然后他们回过头去说，你知道吗？嘿，我们本该对她好点。不，不是他们。
We should have laughed.
It's not that they were unkind.
What'd you say?
I don't remember.
I just chimed in on the conversation and I realized it was just a record scratch.
But then the very next year, I booked a pilot opposite Scott Wolf.
Wow.
Tell him the name of the pilot.
我们应该笑的。倒不是说他们不友善。你当时说了什么？我不记得了。我只是插话聊了聊，然后我意识到这就像是唱片卡壳的声音一样突兀。但就在第二年，我试镜成功了一个飞行集，搭档是斯科特·沃尔夫。哇。告诉大家这个飞行集的名字。
This is amazing.
Rubbing Charlie.
That's a real type of.
Who bounced that around?
Is Scott Wolf, Charlie?
Yeah.
I rubbed him.
I was a masseuse.
这太棒了。揉捏查理。这名字真够奇葩的。谁想出这个点子的？是斯科特·沃尔夫演查理吗？对。我给他按摩。我演个按摩师。
Wow.
And it was like he was a successful doctor.
Yeah.
And he would come to see me as his masseuse.
What is the show?
What is that show?
I was kind of like therapy for him.
But I was the female lead.
哇。剧情是他是个成功的医生。对。他会来找我做按摩。这剧叫什么名字？那是什么剧？我对他来说有点像心理治疗师。但我是女主角。
I did not remind Scott Wolf that I had been on Spinsonson.
Why?
Because I wanted him just forget.
But you know why you shouldn't bring it?
I think you're in sickness is right because, and I'm going to say this, is that you perceived it that way.
Oh, you just.
got deep, Bobby.
Because we perceive things, like personally, and we ruminate about things.
我没有提醒斯科特·沃尔夫我曾经演过《政界小人物》。为什么？因为我希望他彻底忘掉。但你知道为什么你不该提吗？我觉得你的直觉是对的，因为——我要这么说——那是你自己的心理投射。哦，你这话说得太深奥了，鲍比。因为我们会把事情想得很个人化，而且会反复琢磨。
Yeah.
And it might not even be true to them.
Oh, that's so good.
So I do that a lot.
Like, I'll bring it up, something up, and I'll go, I was so embarrassing.
And they're like, we don't really remember that.
What are you talking about?
Yeah.
对。而对他们来说可能根本没这回事。哦，太对了。所以我经常这样。比如，我会提起某件事，然后说，我当时太尴尬了。而他们会说，我们根本不记得那事了。你在说什么呢？对。
And I'm like, oh, and then you kind of go, oh, it's in my mind.
Yeah.
And you lay in bed and you think about it.
And you replay it over and over again.
But it's like, you know, I'm.
sure none of them even remember you being in the show.
That's what I mean.
Like, he didn't see me on day one of our pilot and be like, oh, my gosh, the waitress.
然后我就想，哦，接着你就会意识到，哦，这都是我脑补的。对。然后你躺在床上辗转反侧。一遍又一遍地回想。但我觉得，我敢肯定他们甚至都不记得你在剧里出现过。这就是我的意思。比如，他在我们飞行集的第一天看到我时，并没有说，哦，天哪，那个女服务员。
Yeah.
Who said that weird thing.
He didn't say anything.
Just like until you reminded me, I did not remember about that time you didn't show up to
set because you ever slept.
Like I had.
Yeah, but I've been thinking about that every day since.
But now you can let it go.
对。那个说了句怪话的人。他什么也没说。就像直到你提醒我之前，我都不记得你曾经因为睡过头而缺席片场这回事了。我确实有过。对，但我从那以后每天都在想这事。不过现在你可以放下了。
I'm going to let it go now.
Yeah.
All right.
So that was good podcast.
Thank you for coming on.
Of course, dude.
I want to say watch Nimrods.
我从现在开始放下了。对。对。好啦。这个播客录得真不错。谢谢你来做客。当然啦，老兄。我想说大家去看《神勇小顽童》。
It comes out.
What's the date?
August 14th.
In theaters.
Bobby plays Otis.
He's hilarious.
即将上映。具体日期是什么时候？8月14日。8月14日。各大影院上映。各大影院上映。鲍比饰演奥蒂斯。他太搞笑了。
I play Otis.
And then, you know, it's really good to be here.
We could do this for 10 hours, I think.
We could.
We're a good team.
Don't you think?
We could go on forever.
Yeah.
我演奥蒂斯。然后呢，很高兴能来到这里。我觉得我们能聊上10个小时。我们绝对可以。我们是个好团队。你不觉得吗？我们可以聊到天荒地老。对啊。
I think we're good together.
I do too.
I do.
Oh, my gosh.
Bobby is just so fun and so great to talk to. We talked about things I could never have anticipated.
Yeah. No, that's the great thing about Bobby is he's really, really funny, obviously. So you know you're just going to have a fun time when you're with him. But he isn't afraid to get serious.
Oh, but before we go, Sam, I want to share that you are also in Nimrods. Yes, there's a big crowd scene at the end that I am in. If you have an eagle eye, you should be able to spot me. My friends.
Steve and my friend Samantha. You're at the New Year's Eve big concert. Yes. I just wanted to say,
我觉得我们俩配合得很默契。我也这么觉得。我也是。哦，天哪。鲍比太有趣了，和他聊天简直棒极了。我们聊了一些我完全意料不到的话题。对啊。不，鲍比最棒的地方在于他真的很搞笑，显而易见。所以你知道和他在一起一定会过得很开心。但他并不害怕严肃起来。哦，不过在我们离开之前，萨姆，我想分享一下，你其实也在《神勇小顽童》里。是的，最后有一场盛大的群众戏，我在里面。如果你眼光敏锐的话，应该能认出我。我的朋友史蒂夫和我的朋友萨曼莎。你在跨年夜那个大型演唱会上。是的。我只是想说，
I don't think we talked about that moment since then. I grew up in a real small town in Wisconsin.
I still have a lot of friends and family back there. They often think my life is a lot more
exciting than it is due to this podcast and my social media and stuff like that. That was one
of those moments. I remember leaving being like, I can feast on this for months. Like this is why I left
my small town in Wisconsin. Yeah, that was so cool. Thank you for having me.
I mean, it was really neat.
And when you got there, everybody had to put their phones in, like, a little pouch.
Nobody was allowed to have their phone.
自那以后我们好像就没再聊过那个时刻。我在威斯康星州一个很小的小镇长命百岁……哦不，是长大的。我在那边还有很多亲朋好友。由于这个播客和我的社交媒体什么的，他们经常觉得我的生活比实际要精彩得多。那绝对是其中一个时刻。我记得离开时心想，够我回味好几个月了。这就是我离开威斯康星州小镇的原因。对，太酷了。谢谢邀请我。我是说，这真的太棒了。而且你到那儿的时候，所有人都必须把手机放进一个小袋子里。谁都不准带手机。
But I sneaked pictures of you and your friends.
That's right.
Sam, it's good to know the director's wife.
Yeah.
Well, keep in mind, this is the second cool thing.
You invited me to the table read.
A long time ago.
At the Paladium.
但我偷拍了你和你朋友的照片。没错了。萨姆，认识导演的太太真不错。对啊。好吧，记住，这是第二件酷事。你邀请我去参加剧本围读。很久以前。在帕拉迪奥剧场。
Oh, my gosh.
This is my second time being up close in front with Green Day, thanks to you.
And what a full circle moment that you were.
were at the very first table read of this movie when it was in development.
And I read multiple characters.
So did you, Jenna, because Lee just needed to hear it out loud.
Yes, but Green Day was there.
That's right.
哦，天哪。多亏了你，这是我第二次近距离面对面接触绿日乐队。多奇妙的缘故，你竟然参与了这部电影还在开发阶段时的第一次剧本围读。而且我读了好几个角色。你也是，珍娜，因为比利需要听出声音效果。是的，但绿日乐队就在现场。没错了。
Billy just sat next to me.
Also, did you mention earlier, this is the Sleepy?
Copenhagen Sleepy.
That is bananas.
Banana.
That is a deep cut.
I hope I'm not going to get in trouble for sharing that Sleepy makes an appearance.
That is insane.
比利就坐在我旁边。还有，你刚才提到了吗，那是睡眠喷雾？哥本哈根睡眠喷雾。太疯狂了。太疯狂了。这真是一个冷门彩蛋。希望我不会因为透露睡眠喷雾出场而惹上麻烦。太疯狂了。
Do you need to ask and make sure?
I mean, a few people have mentioned it when they have written about the movie.
So I think at this point, it's coming out on Friday.
Yeah.
That is a deep cut, by the way.
It's a deep cut.
That's awesome.
Well, so cool.
你需要去问问确认一下吗？我是说，当人们写到这部电影时，已经有几个人提到过了。所以我觉得到了这个时候，反正周五就要上映了。对。顺便说一句，这真是一个冷门彩蛋。真是个冷门彩蛋。太棒了。好吧，太酷了。
Everybody goes to see the movie and let's all look for Sam.
And wow, thank you, Bobby Lee, for joining us in the studio today.
He's wonderful.
I love him so much.
Everyone, please remember he has his comedy special.
coming out in November on Hulu,
and be sure to check him out on his two podcasts, Bad Friends.
And Tiger Belly, they're very funny,
大家都去看这部电影，然后一起找找萨姆吧。哇，谢谢鲍比·李今天来录音室做客。他太棒了。我太喜欢他了。大家请记住，他的喜剧专场将于11月在Hulu上线，千万别错过他的两个播客《Bad Friends》。和《Tiger Belly》，它们非常搞笑，
and you can find them on YouTube and wherever you listen to your podcast.
And check all three of us out in the movie Nimrods coming out, August 14th.
Everyone, it is a really, really fun movie to see in a group in the theaters.
So grab your pals.
We'll be there, and we hope you enjoy it.
All right.
We'll see you next week.
See you then.
你可以在YouTube以及任何收听播客的地方找到它们。还有我们三个主演的电影《神勇小顽童》，将于8月14日上映。大家一定记得去影院和大家一起看这部超级无敌有趣的电影。所以带上你的小伙伴们吧。我们会在那里，希望你们能喜欢。好了。我们下周见。回头见。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle and our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer.
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz.
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.
感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Audience呈现，珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的高级制作人是马特·比格尔，音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。Audience执行制作人是利亚·里斯·丹尼斯。本节目由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。